leaked photos reportedly showed the set
of Disney's new version of Snow White
and the Seven Dwarves starring a
Hispanic lady and a bunch of tall guys
initially Disney told The Daily Beast
that the photos were fake but a Disney
spokesman later recanted the denial and
insisted instead that the photos were
real just not official whatever official
means they were obviously taken on set
and of course they were real this is all
Hollywood can do now it just remakes old
stuff because it has no new stories to
tell and it does so in a way that not
only reliably erases white people but at
a deeper level than that just doesn't
make any sense
of course Snow White is brown of course
the dwarves are tall it's 2023 up is
down right is left the next 101
Dalmatians will be played by chihuahuas